[Music]  maybe for you there's a tomorrow but for  some of us there's only today hey sexy  get in no I'm eating get out are you  guys big party night I'm I'm going out  of town  oh my god what's she doing here what's  this what are you doing what happened  last night  what are you talking about I've been  having days off we go all day long are  you okay  it wasn't a dream it really happened  again the only way to escape is to  change watch out for the drought what  trap I had to do something that would  make a difference  maybe things could change  and maybe I could change them  [Music]  hey it's never too late are you in  trouble you can trust me  trust me that's what  maybe for you there's a tomorrow but for  some of us  there's only today but I didn't know any  of that until right before I film  [Music]  you